thank you for joining us America Andrew
is with us in Indianapolis hi Andrew how
are you hey doing pretty good writer
finally get out holy I get a situation
okay
my situation is back in 2012 I had
gotten my BA after 33 years but why was
staying at the hospital this nurse
called the VA and told him that my name
Dan match up and she called med
occurrence of that I had VA insurance
forward back to 1981 she failed the tell
them that I just got it
so what Medicare did is they looked
backs for years and took all the
payments back sold back at that time in
2012 it was $800,000 in debt so I called
Medicare and I asked them if they could
reverse that because someone called them
light and they said that we're not going
to even though Congress allows us
whether we can do it or not since then
I've been homeless repeatedly because my
debt ratios been so high and I'm said to
have a cosigner but last three months I
found the place works I've been able to
get back on my feet and I'm trying to
pay off money off my SUV which I told
$2,000 on that note rent out my visa
which is five hundred to show our
payment history so that at some point I
can move to a better place but I'm
trying to figure out how I can do this
with the rest of the debt load because I
sent letters out to all these places and
pull now I will pay the lowest amount of
money first and then pay the higher
bills somewhere in the gray note and so
on something like the court now I got a
judgment against me so if I would decide
to go to work to pay off these bills
don't just change that but online
disability I get like $1,300 a month
so I'm trying to weigh the decision to a
file bankruptcy for the rest of them in
your mouth or just you painted over time
okay so you're living off the disability
yes okay but the $800,000 is still there
well for the last uh four years of paid
close to eight hundred back on the
smaller amount so it's probably down to
me be six hundred thousand or five
hundred thousand I still owe a lot of my
acquaintances and some of my friends
impassable you need to file bankruptcy
to give you a new start I just haven't
had a chance a little bit homeless
because I haven't been able to get a
place because I've needed a cosigner I'm
glad you're getting back on your feet
that's good news yeah and yeah it sounds
like this debt you're either going to
have to have an attorney hired to
reverse this debt and maybe you can find
someone to represent you on a pro bono
basis to get this ridiculous situation
unraveled and that way the debt goes
away if the debt is not going to go away
and you know you're trying to live on a
couple thousand dollars a month you're
not going to pay six hundred thousand or
eight hundred thousand back
that's just mathematically not going to
happen and so you would be a candidate
for a chapter seven bankruptcy at that
point and get completely cleared up and
you know have that fresh start assuming
that debt is all bankrupt able and I
don't know the situation with what
you've described whether or the Medicaid
is going to Medicare is going to be
there or not on that so you know I think
you need to seek some legal counsel and
get some advice on that what you would
have to do to file bankruptcy or you'd
have to do to get see if this situation
can be fought and what I would do is
check with some of your local churches
since you're you know in a program
coming off the street trying to get your
feet on the ground and I would check
with some local churches and see if one
of them can lead you and maybe maybe
they can lead you toward an attorney
would help you you know as a ministry to
get things going here I don't have that
resource or I would give it to you but I
think that's what you're going to have
to do and then that will lead you to
your decision as to whether or not
bankruptcy is really your only option if
you can't clear it by fighting it you're
going to have to clear it with
bankruptcy because the numbers you're
giving me aren't going to work so under
any you know under anything short of
some kind of modern miracle but I
appreciate you calling and thank you for
joining us
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
Oh